Mayday Mayday Mayday there's a cactus
1549 we're gonna end up in the Hudson
Wow
Tom Hanks in the new movie Sully and it
looks fantastic Cameron I riveted to
this because we travel so much you just
sat down with Tom I did we got tongue
all about The Miracle on the Hudson for
sure but Kevin I know you remember this
one
Tom diving headfirst into the water
about 30 years ago in the movie splash
it's a classic right so how does tell
feel about the movie being remade with
the twist
splash remake Channing Tatum Julianne
bell in Bell fantastic why not give it a
shot
the twist this time is that Jillian is
the human and Channing is the mermaid
mermaid
Jillian Bill's gonna have a blast but
she's just gotta love that guy if she
can work up a romance with Channing
Tatum Chris well she's a better actor
than I am but that bad dude
Channing Tatum what'd it do exactly what
did she say that if she can find some
reason to be attracted to him I'm
rooting for Tom was only 27 when splash
was released in 1984 well Hanks just
turned 60 and his wife Rita posted this
shirtless shot from their vacation did
you get photo approval did you get to
check it out you think my wife gives me
photos
mine does occasional no no no what might
what my wife does is pose the photo for
a very long time let's put your head on
my shoulder get on the other shoulder
come around into the Sun just a little
bit you know let's move because I want
to have this little battle
Rita might direct Tom and family photos
but on the set of Sully
it was Clint Eastwood at the helm we had
complicated scenes with a lot of
dialogue with a lot of people so I said
let's get together at the hotel in
Atlanta and we'll just run the dialogue
we will recite the dialogue so we'll
know the dialogue and I got a call from
Tim Bourne the frozen hey the boss
doesn't like you guys getting together
rehearsing without him he doesn't like
that I said tell the boss were not
rehearsing we're reciting it's a big big
big big first of all I love the
impression and second surprised to hear
that but another person that you might
call through meticulous is real captain
Sully himself Tom told me that Sully
walked him through every single scene in
the movie even the scenes that Tom
wasn't in how was the movie it was
awesome
so so much better than the story you
think you know